howdy partner Walter burn AZ ACK and
this is top five as cars three hits
theaters this weekend I think it's time
to take a look at a certain famous
animation studio an animation studio who
has been pumping out mostly hits for
over 20 years now that's right today
we're taking a look at Pixar starting
with Toy Story in 1995 Pixar Animation
Studios has been an undeniable seal of
quality when it comes to animated
features year after year movie after
movie Pixar has received dozens of
awards for excellence in their craft
stretching the limits of what a viewer
can get out of an animated film most of
their projects have the ability to be
enjoyed by both children and adults
their trademark humor razor-sharp wit
and intelligent emotional stories up the
game in the animation field from day one
each film being a unique angle on a
different issue and present it in a way
that still feels fresh and exciting
Pixar's filmography is filled with many
more hits than misses but which movies
represent the best of Pixar it's a
difficult question to answer what we're
going to do just that right now these
are the top five best Pixar movie number
five monsters Inc I have a soft spot for
this one an earlier Pixar feature
monsters Inc had some great sequences
and characters in it that are held
together by its powerful emotional
Center monsters and best friends James P
Sullivan and Mike Wazowski worked for
monsters Inc which supplies the monster
world with screams from children that
power their city Monstropolis when a
human child sneaks into the monster
world through an open closet Mike and
Sulley are the first two finder with the
whole city looking for this little girl
named boo by Sulley they get roped into
a conspiracy that ends up being very
dangerous for all involved John Goodman
Sulley and Billy Crystal's Mike are a
great team in this the bond they shared
in the comedy that ensued worked really
well
means you both of us together now put
that thing back where it came from or so
help me it's a musical yes put that
thing back where it came from also help
me so help me correctly their friendship
isn't perfect though I really like that
they have to work through some issues
together after Buu enters the picture
none of that matters now
none of it mattered what wait a second
none of it matters okay no good great so
now the truth comes out doesn't it the
concept of Monsters Inc is still very
interesting to me I love the idea of the
monster world being parallel but
separate to arts and to them it's just
business as usual of course Buu is
adorable her relationship with Sully
feels so genuine and bittersweet I would
have loved to see a sequel to Monsters
Inc where Sully tried visiting Buu when
she's older that idea seemed like a
no-brainer but instead we get a prequel
with Mike and Sully at college monsters
university isn't great but I still like
seeing these two together again the
music is also very strong in this movie
I love the theme and instrumentals
throughout
[Music]
other than that I just think Monsters
Inc is really funny it has moments I
still laugh at as hard as when I saw it
for the first time the fingers are
killing machine the scare floor will be
painted yeah little one i cretin okay
first of all it's creepy you're going to
threaten me do it properly maybe one day
we'll get that sequel but even without
it
I think Monsters Inc is one of Pixar's
best number four The Incredibles an
instant classic The Incredibles is in
just a great animated movie it's a great
superhero movie mr. incredible was on
top of the world as a famous superhero
who led a life of adventure and even
married fellow hero Elastigirl after all
super-powered activities are banned by
the government they're forced to live
dull everyday lives now with three
children and living a less than exciting
life mr. incredible is recruited to stop
an out-of-control robot however
everything is not as it seems eventually
mr. Incredibles whole family gets
involved in a battle with a dastardly
old fan turned foe who doesn't love The
Incredibles Brad Bird wrote and directed
this hit and a lot of people adore this
film it's got a great mix of tone that
finds the right balance between action
humor and genuine family drama then this
will make you stronger no that's what
this is some sort of workout I can't
lose you again
I can't not again
I'm just crawling enough it's just a
slick film that is very rewatchable from
the start that features mr. incredible
and Elastigirl and their prime
crime-fighting days to the whole
Incredibles family teaming up it works
great on every level including its
spot-on sense of humor and timing what
may be another team of superheroes
should take a hint from this movie
number three oh if you saw my top-five
best Disney animated movie couples you
know how much I love Carl and Ellie's
life story at the beginning of this film
but it's much more than that Carl
Fredricksen is an old man who's lost
many things after a violent incident
requires him to move to a retirement
home Carl decides to fulfill a lifelong
dream before they can take him away he
patches his house to thousands of
balloons and floats towards Paradise
Falls to live out the rest of his life
unbeknownst to Carl a young boy named
Russell unintentionally Stow's away on
his porch when they arrive at Paradise
Falls they discover beautiful landscapes
exotic animals and a surprising famous
figure with Carl being set up so well in
the first few minutes we fully
understand his flaws which makes for a
very unique character driven movie his
relationship with Russell is really nice
to see developed because as we find out
they're sort of the missing piece they
need in each other's lives
I like that curb might sound boring but
I think the boring stuff is the stuff I
remember the most
I love the Charles Muntz character the
old newsreel footage of him at the top
of the film billed to legend up
perfectly as this eccentric Howard
Hughes type figure when we see him later
it's a nice twist for Carl's character I
will admit we could have used just one
more scene of him and Carl talking
before he turned on them that all
happened just a pinch too fast the
action in the climax is really well done
and gets you on the edge of your seat
the thrills of that battle in the skies
even more than what I was expecting also
those dogs are hilarious squirrel my
master is good a smart boy great leader
kickin it pretty to check against
rejection yet still one of Pixar's most
poignant films up is a special one
number two inside out when this came out
in theaters a few years ago I was
absolutely blown away inside out is
nearly flawless joy anger fear disgust
and sadness are emotions that live in
Riley's head she's a happy active
eleven-year-old girl but when her and
her parents moved from Minnesota to San
Francisco her emotions are thrown into
disarray joy and sadness are
accidentally thrust out of headquarters
leaving just anger fear and disgust to
control Riley's actions i love inside
out probably more every time I see it
the world inside Riley's head is so
cleverly laid out and we get to explore
a lot of it with joy and sadness from
abstract thought to Riley's imaginary
boyfriend I would die for Riley oh I've
never seen him before I live in Canada
to dream studios
and even bring boy taken to the moon for
me bing-bong sacrifice is so sad but as
this movie teaches us sadness is
important it's that complexity that
raises this film above most of Pixar's
other work I can't talk about this movie
without mentioning Lewis Black as anger
perfect casting he was maybe my favorite
character
congratulation sanfrancisco your bro and
beats up five star alliance and now you
when you add this film's great score on
top of everything else inside out is a
Titan among Titans when talking about
animated features on to number they'll
make you mine those ripples and Joan any
of the following films could have easily
made it into the top 5 ordering this
list was very difficult its Pixar so
before we get to number 1 here are some
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Pixar movie is
the Toy Story trilogy yes this is a bit
of a cheat yes this is technically a top
seven but all three films are equally as
good and I wanted to highlight more than
just two non Toy Story movies the Toy
Story movies focus on Andy's living toys
Woody Buzz Lightyear and many more as
they help him grow up while trying not
to be thrown out lost or replaced the
first film introduced Buzz Lightyear the
new cool toy and what his insecurities
about being replaced as Andy's favorite
in the second film what he finds out
he's an old rare toy based on a classic
TV series after being stolen by a toy
shop owner looking to sell him for big
bucks the rest of Andy's toys try to
find woody and return him to Andy Toy
Story 3 takes place years later Andy is
a 17 year old about to leave for college
with woody only not being played with in
a very long time the rest of his toys
are accidentally thrown away but end up
at a daycare center that seems perfect
at first but is actually a house of
horrors for new toys things get
dangerous as they try to escape the evil
clutches of the daycares leader lot so
hug and bay will take this movie by
movie so what the real buzz like your
your tiger an action figure
you are a child plaything you are a sad
strange little man the original film was
the first full-length computer animated
feature which sets so many trends and
created the Pixar tone and humor I am
top though I don't get it
you uncultured swine what are you
looking at your hockey puck
I am mrs. Nesbitt no problem good plug I
still remember going to see this with my
parents and brother it was supposed to
be a surprise but I guess where we were
going in the car on the way there and
was so excited many people had similar
memories regarding this first film it's
irreplaceable
[Music]
Toy Story 2 continued the saga with some
great development for woody and added
classic new characters that fit in
perfectly Jessie and her backstory for
example is heartbreaking it added a new
level of depth to these movies every
hour spent together in my heart
we even see a very rare moment when
woody gives up on Annie the other toys
trying to convince him to come back with
them is an awesome character saying you
are a toy for how much longer
one more ripping Eddie's done with me
and what do i do then bypass you tell me
somewhere in that pedestal is a toy who
taught me that life's only worth living
if you're being loved by a kid it's very
hard to decide but this first sequel
might be the strongest of the trilogy
[Music]
for Story 3 came out 11 years after -
and shows us what happens when Andy
grows up it's brilliant
great story character and emotion that
incinerator scene is still
nerve-wracking
you
[Music]
yeah and e-blast playtime with woody
buzz in the gang could very well be the
best moment in any of the three films
but the thing that makes what he's
special
is he'll never give up on you ever he'll
be there for you no matter what with Toy
Story 4 on its way I'll be honest we
don't need it
Toy Story 3 wraps things up perfectly
I'm actually kind of disappointed
they're doing another one when this one
ended things on an amazing note we'll
have to see what they come up with you
bet I'll be there on opening night while
cars have been Pixar's highest reviewed
franchise that doesn't change all the
brilliance this studio has put out and
continues to put out on a consistent
basis it's one-of-a-kind in terms of
creativity and quality I'm looking
forward to what the future of Pixar
brings and you should be too I want to
hear what you guys think what is your
favorite Pixar movie leave a comment and
let me know for more content subscribe
to my personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome Walter like my new Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter beef
and follow me on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week as we go
to war beast wars
[Music]
you